what's going on man is it going good to
see you here yes yeah have a seat Dave
portly is here are the latest person to
be in charge of a channel yeah it's
serious rush Channel 93 that's where the
shows on right well barstools is on 12
to 2 on rush channel 93 but you guys are
getting your own channel here right and
it's still gonna be 93 I think we're
just flipping the name to the rush
yeah so is everybody at rush like [ __ ]
you I'm trying to stay away from the
rush people because I don't know what's
happening what is rush it's combat
sports but is it we're not gonna have
that channel anymore
baby is moving I don't know lots of
what's happening in serious which I
don't have the answer to okay I know
this I know that's our channel they're
gonna be pissed dude yeah so the if
there was a combat channel on there it's
not gonna be on there comes your choice
that's a they're gonna move it somewhere
else if they keep it yeah maybe it'll be
online exclusive sometimes they do that
a lot uh wanna hypothesize I'm guessing
that I have no idea what are you guys in
ESPN was that was that a bad fit to
begin with or did they screw you I would
say they screwed us it was also a bad
fit they liked Dan and they liked P of T
so they like they like part my take it
was popular was big they didn't like
barstools they never liked barstool I
knew they didn't like parcel it looked
me across the table say we don't like
barstool but we like them in hindsight
maybe you shouldn't go into business
with somebody like that because they
defend you or bother you because it's
your brand yeah yeah it's it but you
know it's it was good for those guys and
if we got our name out there I I have a
belief I think Marcel is good I think
people who don't know about us if we
find them if we can reach our demo we
generally win so yes it offended me but
I just kind of picked my tongue I'm like
let's roll with this and see what
happens
and you and that you made them put the
name bar stool on the show right they
wanted to take the name off yeah and and
what what finally got them to put the
name on you said without it you don't
get the show there was no way I was
doing it basically you know weird way I
thought you spin just thought I or Erica
who's our CEO that we were stupid like
yeah we're gonna let you take a little
website you can take to your better guys
to your best guys we're gonna make it
seem like they're full-time you
ESPN employees make it seem like as our
show and you guys have nothing to do
with it
they weren't paying us a ton of money
and so why would we ever do that so the
trade for us was put our logo front and
center put it everywhere the commercial
yeah so there's no and we knew they'd
get they get blowback on it we knew it
because of any time we do something just
blowback so for us it's like all right
you get them but you're gonna take a lot
of heat and we they thought they were
ready for me they weren't were you
shocked that they did I mean literally
one episode will you surprised it was
the first episode usually give something
three or four but it wasn't even the
episode right it was like it happened to
have been one episode but it's not like
they saw the episode like we can't air
that correct in a weird way it's so bar
still like we're planning on doing
I want to almost like a Rocky Horror
Picture Show once a year on the air date
like rent out a big theater and just
rerun the first episode because who gets
a show who has one show right and we may
be the only people that's ever happened
one show right I mean that's impossible
and no no specific and it's the show is
exactly delivered as it was promised
right did say that though they did say
that he what skipper said the ESPN live
guy runs he has been his main thing was
we're a in hindsight we thought we could
separate ourselves from barceló barceló
and we think they're gonna say something
in the future that's gonna cause problem
all stuff that well then why'd you do
the show in the first place what was it
do they did they cite something in the
episode or did they just say no it was a
ponder it was it was stuff that one of
it so one of their own employees Sam
ponder I had trashed three years prior
and she on them basically the eve of the
show brought it up and I don't think
anybody did intentionally you think Oh
thousand percent it was a well held
grudge which I sort of respect yeah yeah
I mean ESPN knew they brought the
complaints to them before our show and
they said we don't care we're doing it
we we want their audience we think it's
a good fit they did not anticipate her
going public with the complaints what
she did and caused them especially in
the climate we're in right now sure with
the wine scene stuff it's just anything
that even even though it has nothing to
do with that
everything's getting rolled into one big
mess you had trashed her publicly for
her work or her appearance or what was I
don't even know the trash I trashed her
twice
she wrote a tweet or she tweeted during
the Ray Rice stuff that she doesn't
understand how a website that puts up
pictures of pretty girls can now condemn
Ray Rice for punching his fiancee sure
and I ripped her for that because to me
that's like how can you not just not
disassociate like we put I can say a
girl's hot and put a picture of a girl
in bikini you don't advocate hitting
them when you fight all right the Sports
Illustrated swimsuit model isn't
followed up with [ __ ] jaw surgery ads
yeah exactly so I mean to me it was an
outrageous take and I and I ripped her
and at the end of it I actually called
her a bible-thumping freak which I think
she didn't like what's not even that bad
and by the way her husband there was an
article like last week he just came out
she was married to an NFL quarterback
he's been retired for like four years he
just said he no longer blames God for
when he stunk in the NFL just now Wow
just now so I like that he's blaming God
that at least thank God [ __ ] you I
[ __ ] everything she does is like a
quote from the Bible and fine what
everything but I so I wrote that blog
and a colorful thing and then the other
so that was one of them which I actually
totally stand by because I thought her
tweet was ridiculous big cat and I did a
we do like a pic and podcast NFL games
she went through a phase she used to be
the reporter on ESPN gameday college
football and I watch college football I
love that show and she had a kid and the
kids start showing up in every telecast
and I was like enough of this kid I
don't want to see the kid anymore
she dressed super conservatively I said
something that I wish I called her [ __ ]
I wish I didn't I said stop being
approved you [ __ ] which makes no sense
and I just was slinging it and I can't
sling it like that anymore because if
you use those words people come back and
they attack us we're open for it I wish
I didn't use that word but that was what
she brought up even it's not it's not
being approved you [ __ ] is like saying
exactly it silly makes no sense and
she's not a [ __ ] exactly so it's my
point but nobody
thing right but it wasn't right but the
word right exactly just it raises now
and then we do what our crowd does we
dug up a million tweets our crowd she's
using the word [ __ ] oh yeah well that's
fair then yeah that's how I would look
at it but that's not how you know we
have this image about us and we're white
guys that probably are eat like we we
have a long history of battling for
whatever reason with and I don't want to
say feminist in one way because there's
a lot of women who consider themselves
feminists who love us they're like wait
a minute
don't tell us what to laugh at sure we
get there trying to make jokes but for
whatever reason it we've had a long
history and we make fun of everybody
probably like you guys do we don't care
creed color race Jen we make fun of you
myself included I mean I say that like
we make Jew jokes I'm Jewish I'm the
most anti-semitic Jew who's ever lived
because people don't know it like
they're anti-semitic they don't it's
like wait a minute timeout like sure
we're not but that group and especially
right now they people think we hate
women which is wildly untrue so if you
say hey Dave porn I said [ __ ] three
years ago
doesn't matter it'll context doesn't
matter anything it's it's game on and
people come from every side of the
Internet to attack us I think it's
interesting that you guys like it's it's
to me I feel like if I were running bar
stool I would not be trying to associate
with big brands like ESPN or even Sirius
or any of these things because I feel
like you guys have been successful
because you've been able to live inside
your own bubble where people who want
the content can come get the content and
people that want to [ __ ] with you cannot
penetrate the bubble because it's your
thing the minute that you start
associating with bigger brands that's
when people can show and get you and you
kind of get yeah we close to the Sun
yeah we've had both I mean I think he
has been serious serious I think is
obviously very different and much more
supportive its uncensored here the
incorrect right so that that's a huge
step you know but in the end I looked at
the ESPN thing and I thought about him
like if I if you said hey Dave this is
going down the same exact way you do the
deal but it's gonna be one show people
gonna say the worst thing ever would you
do it again I probably would because the
the the good thing we have churning
group who bought us that's what we did
the deal with literally gaming content
control and they haven't wavered they
really haven't backed down they knew
what they were getting into so yeah it
creates all this controversy but the
message that was going across the
country hey there's some rogue very
unpeaceful running around the internet
that's why I was doing the ESPN show to
begin with to get that message out I
thought that they did these guys a favor
though unintentionally because ESPN now
is seen as this [ __ ] disney-owned
you know nothing controversial and then
here you guys come like these [ __ ]
drunken maniacs and they make the
defective signing you up and then one
one episode they're like I get out we
can have it you guys are good sports
fans were able to look at like barstool
whoo I mean most are already exposed to
you but people who weren't or like we
meant that those are the guys like me
and then I feel like ESPN and all the
press that went on after that while some
people were like oh this is just
terrible for barstool I was like that's
a better commercial than having your
logo on their TV once a week total ever
would have totally the business side
where it gets a little tricky is you
know we have some advertisers just like
the curing thing that's going on you
know just outside influences yeah can
then even if they don't believe it's
like is this worth the headache of
people calling up not back and the
people call up are the people get
offended like the ones that get mad
about this they're the same people who
will create a commotion you know be
interesting if Twitter didn't happen I
would like I feel like 95% people
couldn't get their voice the helpful
part be if you're around people who like
you guys called advertisers that abandon
you or [ __ ] with you that's what the
curate thing is interesting is is
because they they they're sticking up
for Hannity by doing that so sometimes
if people who like a show stick up for
it instead of just people who hate it
targeting it it balances out and the
advertisers won't back out because if
they they know that you have more people
supporting them being on your show they
won't walk away and I believe this I've
said this a lot
look I really believe our crowd for the
most part is is the silent majority most
people don't have that knee-jerk
reaction man I'll start complaining the
sponsors or they just want to like laugh
and go along their day so
you know we continue as long as in part
of what we do we get to just stay I've
always Parcells always been good not
being dependent on just big brand
advertising whether we sell merch or we
do events or whatever where our
consumers can support us directly do you
worry based on like where the culture is
going that inevitably you guys are gonna
have to soften you guys are gonna have
to become not like totally sort of PC
and super just happy nice to everybody
but continue the way you can't say squat
anymore like let's continue to dial back
dial back dial back no I is weird
because before this I feel like we're in
a very strange bubble and it almost is
the combo I think is it's Trump the
Weinstein thing it's like this weird
bubble but I've been doing it for 15
years and I consistently say every
everything's moving our way like the
content on the internet like more people
trying to be similar to what the stuff
we're doing than vice-versa and I think
will come out of it um we're just a
weird sensitive spot right now plus even
as you like Sam said if you if you have
to start like dialing back a teeny bit
it's not like the culture is staying
stagnant and you're dialing back to the
culture because the culture is always
dialing back yeah see here you're just
matching yeah like so even if you go
back to clicks the culture has got my
[ __ ] three clicks so you're still
gonna be considered uncomfortable for a
lot of people or oh my god they're
saying this like matter maybe you can't
go out and say the things we could say
1990 but you can still do a lot more
than most and you know just being
smarter about like using the word [ __ ]
like I've said I you know I should just
and I used to I should just call guys
[ __ ] and um you know like guys constant
girls [ __ ] like there's little ways
to like get around it yeah or just say
like inside these child words instead of
saying that just call everyone like
poopoo heads like I know it sounds
ridiculous but I can say the same exact
thing get my meaning across and just
change like a little word and I think
we'll be the same but it just doesn't
open that we just don't put the ball on
tea for people who hate us well that's
what it is like you're they comment stop
acting like a prude you [ __ ] it's all
about the words right has nothing to do
with the meaning or what you're actually
saying it's just the triggering Kuroda
unquote words that are being used and no
and you can easily get that same exact
sort of smart message out there
without you and I was wearing that right
in that in that context I think prude is
the insult because you're saying hey
you're a [ __ ] so stop acting like a
prude I think prude is almost the
insulting word in that in that context
yeah I mean and again like I just say it
in ways that like I stand by that whole
rant I don't think guys are watching
game day to watch Sam pond or young
males tote her baby around the
television like that was my and I just
do it I'm passed away which is just
talking like I talked to a buddy at a
bar do you think yes PA they are they're
losing subscriptions there's something
happening there and it's maybe because
the internet people don't need it as
much as they used to they don't need the
[ __ ] sports scores to go watch they
can just get on your phone I also think
the fact that they fire people they
don't stand by people who say things so
they just say this zero byte to them
anymore but I don't see ESPN being
around forever I think they're
eventually gonna to go under I don't
know I you know I they're not my
favorite people right now but they're
still a behemoth the game rights aren't
they are they not doing it past this
contract I don't know I don't know what
their current I mean I think that's why
they're in so much problems because they
sign these huge contracts and then
everything move kind of technology wise
internet wise and just naturally people
are watching less but I I don't see them
going anywhere anytime soon I mean I
said I hate them I still watch them just
because there's certain things I got a
watch for what we do so what are you
what are you doing you're on your
channel you only got to tell January
that's kind of a quick yeah do it are
you just gonna put like the barstool
podcast on the channel so the podcast
will run on the channel we have our
existing show which will currently and
then we're gonna launch three more shows
I believe Pat McAfee who works for us
the X Kol sponsor a real funny dude is
gonna have one I think we're gonna have
Dallas Braden who is an actually xes
being IX Oakland a pitcher and Brian
Wilson the guy remember the guy with the
beard for the Giants oh yeah yeah
they're gonna have a show they're like
both weirdly Beverly pitcher yep okay
and it is weird because one of those
things you know a lot of the guys at
ESPN are probably pretty funny but under
ESPN they have like handcuffs on them
yeah so we take the handcuffs off and
these guys like whoa we don't have those
personalities I guess that's part of it
right the reason you want to get
connected is because it's one thing to
go to ESPN people
to work at ESPN and be like hey I'll
give you a podcast on barstool it's
another thing to be like you can have
your show various XM bar snow and it
helps with it helps with the talent and
then we hired Julie Stewart Pink's who
is a very funny woman who's again
someone you take the handcuffs off and
then we're looking we said there's so
many people I think who like what Sirius
XM can offer in which in us it's like
just totally unfiltered like we'll stand
behind you you can say whatever you want
so we're looking for other people he
said that because we've got 24 hours to
fill but yeah so that's a lot of time
yeah yeah a replay we'd give you we give
you a replay yeah no we'll be in the
replay business business so do you uh
one thing that you guys have kind of
become notorious for is not not taking
the high road necessarily will never
take the high road right we live on the
low road is that that we that's where
the kings of the mud like you never know
on a given evening who you've decided to
just go to war way right like I feel
like they're they're just like little
because it's like the barstool fans are
so our maniacs right and there's so I
mean they're similar to the fans here
but like they're so in tune to
everything that nobody says anything
about barstool without it getting back
and the minute anybody like he could be
some schlocky DJ in like Sheboygan yeah
he says something about Mars Oh a month
take your platform [ __ ] this guy that's
something that people who don't like us
criticize we are not very good at
turning the other cheek so if you insult
us and we find out about it we respond
and doesn't even matter if I respond or
one of our bigger personalities respond
that then everybody's like basically
collectively turns their head it's like
who is this guy who is just came out of
the woodwork and a lot of people say we
should ignore it because you know we
know that there's gonna be this big
response and with it there's always
gonna be like 20 people go way overboard
who we don't condone yeah but it's like
we're you know we're trying to be witty
or or have things and I want like great
this person's like oh man why did you go
there actually the nicer ones that we
have that's like don't go there like
though
speak for us get him out never put it
have you ever put a show on your network
your podcast network whatever it is that
your own fans turn on and you're like oh
no no I mean our fans I assume it's
similar to you they're the meanest to us
until but it's like a family it's like
hey we can say this guy is the worst and
all this [ __ ] until someone [ __ ] with
you until somebody else I you can't say
that's like so our guys get trashed no
matter what and we trash each other I
mean I'm one of the Kings like we've had
you know I pulled a show we gave a guy
his own show Nate at night and I
cancelled it after one episode so I mean
y-you can't it sucked
like it was so bad in he was such a pain
there's no redemption you know I didn't
want to even give him a show I'm like
your shows gonna stink but if you were a
spider-man he's a he's just a unique
weird dude which I think plays like if
you do the show with a spider-man mask
on you gotta wear it the whole time
I'll give you the show he's like no that
makes fun of the show I won't do that I
want to take this serious like this
shows gonna stink I don't wanna give it
to you he begged me so much like all
right I know I almost wanted to do it
just to prove how bad it would be and it
was horrible right he may come back
though in serious yeah oh yeah okay but
you told me show stunk and II took it
yeah oh yeah
he didn't cry about it he cried a lawyer
will still employees that come in and
they stop being creative because one of
their co-workers doesn't like them how
did you handle that as a boss like if
like you notice that one of your people
in the bar stool office was like soaking
around and had their atomic grow up you
have what is this going on you walked in
yeah yeah he was he was he was upset
because one of the other staffers not
another breast staffer doesn't he
doesn't like it you gotta just tell them
to grow up go or what we're doing like
we have a couple rivalries we just
bought a redneck like boxing company so
with wrong
we're throwing gloves on them and they
get in the ring why don't we think of
that you can help you die yeah I'm
saying you could actually have a fight
you there boy now that we're sore in the
same family you know them in our ring so
you want to have
boxes are in our event you're more than
what you guys do you guys have like a
license for that oh yeah we bought it we
bought a company okay where do they
fight rough and rowdy West Virginia City
West Virginia for oh we're starting at
license other areas but December panting
it yeah December 15th West Virginia
rowdy yeah this is just like a schlock
like boxing it's think like yes think
like Butterbean tough man except nobody
like that but because I've gone to hunt
professionals know I'm professor I've
gone twice through it and it was like
the most amazing thing I've seen because
public thing about boxing the better you
are the almost boring of the fight
because they're sort of they're better
at defending them yeah these guys run
out to the ring full-speed chin first
someone's even knocked down or they're
out of gas
any of them lackluster boxers it is not
the sweet science it is a completely
different sport just somebody who's
watched boxing on TV they can throw a
couple punches and thinks they should
get in a ring that's pretty much what it
is it's it's electric and then you know
before one guy before the first fights
over the next guys are in the ring and
there's grudge matches it's pretty
entertaining so if these guys want to
fight they give them the green light
where are you going from West Virginia
like what's the next place you're
looking at like so we're license down
South Carolina and North Carolina I mean
the goal is to try to get it like
everywhere and get the cliches of every
state so Massholes guidos in new york
like I just love everything like UFC had
to fight for decades yeah to get
legalized in New York and you're like
yep and we're bright well they did if
we've looked at those like UFC late a
lot of the groundwork in the same
convention in to be honest UFC started
like remember early ufc's like yeah
what's crazy yeah putting like five
hundred pound guys in his like rope and
like choking them out you didn't see
what wasn't happening
you'd have like tank Abbott yeah I'm
shorts versus some guy in a literally
it's just a guy swinging versus a guy
doing karate while yeah I remember
watching that be like what am i watching
that's sort of what we have but these
aren't new the difference is MMA was a
different sport you're just bringing
boxing which is kind of a sport that's
already established here right
so is it the same rules in boxing or
different same okay so you might have an
easier time because boxing is already
legal here right it's just you have to
get around the idea of these people are
trying to fight or not skilled
whatsoever in that profession what is it
that would cause what would what is the
next step to make them professionals
like what do you do to become a
professional probably skill I'm wanting
to I mean these guys never would like
for this tournament there's been around
a little bit if you win the tournament
twice
you can't fight anymore like that it's
purposely not to put people in with like
killers right right then somebody can
knocked out quickly right yeah like
really hurt did you did your CEO does
she get it or do you have to sell her on
something like she gets it now this are
investors were like what are you buying
and it's all part and part of those
crazy it sounds like what is this guy
talking about you bought this tough man
competition
it's all part of I don't want parcel to
have to depend on advertisers so right
this is something where our crowd it's a
pay-per-view event so we did a first one
when we went down there before we owned
it and we sold like 13,000 of them in a
day without too much promotion for five
bucks we're gonna do $9.99 and I think
we can sell a lot it's always where
guess what I don't care if people don't
like us don't like us our crowd likes us
in here's a way we can like my
especially because you can get your
personalities on there as well right
like you can have the tough man fight I
was like Rogan of this event I was like
the play-by-play guy last time right
switch people like it was half comedy
half like weirdness it was just a very
unique mish-mosh of what barstool is and
then the same way this is happening
whoever's arguing on the barstool show
your barstool podcaster on the run it's
smart to to not be a slave to the
advertisers because that will give you
so much more freedom in that you can
[ __ ] your brand right because the
advertisers look they get a couple of
complaints they just panic they're not
even being dicks they're like we're
spending a lot of money we're getting
complaints we're gonna walk away yeah I
mean it's it's always with the
advertisers and I'm in doing it I was
selling it if someone's like with this
blows up that's my ass on the line do I
need this headache like in most time you
ever know you ever seen no-holds-barred
the movie oh yeah that's what you're
doing the Battle of the tough guys that
was their whole like network like it was
just bar fights and it was like the
Battle of the tough guys that is
sort of what it is except that these
guys are just not professionals I mean
there's a market for it there really
isn't it doesn't blow your mind that
right now because I just realized that
my head that now you get this thing set
up where you're gonna be able to do live
events and now you've got a vehicle to
do something that other brands don't
have you can broadcast the play-by-play
live on Sirius is that we can watch like
UFC doesn't have right a radio
counterpart to broadcast right but
you'll be able to sri dick ulis like
spectacle in NY yeah and with that we
plan on doing all that and again we're
good like we did it last Hartman and we
can tell when we have something like
people like what is just an even me it
was four hours I went by in a heartbeat
it's like I hadn't in the characters
from the backwoods of West Virginia
where we did this I I haven't been in a
place where there was no cell phone
service for forty five minutes like I
you couldn't use your phone's you mean I
satellite phone in one of those place it
was so remote I mean there was
Confederate flags every I think they
thought they could I think they thought
they won the Civil War everywhere there
was there was signs like last time since
we had a coal mining accident two days
ago you want me where am I you probably
didn't mention to them that you were
Jewish you they woulda said what is that
we have a clip of a guy full Confederacy
outfit like full and like what do you
guys do around here on Friday nights for
like fun I was doing other crowd
injuries because we do a lot of walking
[Laughter]
we do a lot of walk it but they must
love that you guys come there but love
it like this big company this crazy
company that shows up and well we are
they don't answer that Dave I don't know
but they see the camera right they
didn't have cell phones like you
couldn't like we had to bring our own
internet ID never been placed like
where'd you go it's like we stayed 45
minutes away that was the closest
lodging and it was I mean once you got
the car it's you were disconnected from
the world you are are you actively
fighting this idea that like barstool is
promoting this kind of bro bro bro bro
culture that is all like white male
and and yeah we make fun of everybody
but we're white men so of course we can
make fun of everybody like is that
something because that's the deposits it
bothers me but it feels like fighting
the tides a little bit I mean we'll hire
anybody at any time who I think is funny
I started the company I grew up in a
slightly upper middle class like white
neighborhood I've hired who like I know
and friends I mean we've had different
like we've we've had women and like
jenna Marbles who's a gigantic youtube
celebrity like I hired her like out of a
tanning salon she was our first like
female employee we launched a female
website you know we've had like the guy
who runs complex sports we hired he
started it is what it is I mean and then
at the same time I look at like Seinfeld
like you know that that's who is what
was Seinfeld's audience probably similar
to our audience I would think like demo
wise that's a pretty good audience still
they have I
it's tough thing to fight I don't I
think our guys are normal guys I don't
think just because you're white like bro
that means necessarily bad things even
though that seems to have a bad
connotation so I flip flop a little bit
cuz I know you guys a while ago cuz it
ended up on Sirius got into a fight with
Peter Rosenberg online well that guy was
like crazy are you gonna go up to hot 97
and talk to her yeah if he wants us to I
mean that guy why did you fight with him
he could because we had a Super Bowl
party and he trashed it out of the blue
he's like this was party was everything
I thought there'd be there's all these
NFL white NFL quarterbacks and all these
hot chicks there it's like terrible so I
think we're trashing of the party in he
texted our guys and like asked for an
invite he's like I'm dying to go to this
and they just went and trashed us did he
get the invite he did he was there oh he
did shop okay and then he he murdered
it's like dude what are you doing why
you in in he just seemingly it's a hard
thing because I think there's some times
there is validity do people like with
like white bros and what I don't think
we exemplify that but he was just mad
because we were white like that that
seemed to be his only complaint yeah
like there was nothing else beyond it's
like well you wants to apologize like if
we had well if like Warren Moon was at
the
party you would've been alright with it
like I know but can you imagine if say
sway threw a party and he had a bunch of
black players there and can you imagine
somebody going out and go all this just
a bunch of black guys there like it
would never happen anyway right and
again it's a weird thing because you
don't want there are certainly some
times there's a validity to it but to be
I went to a bar stool party at the Super
Bowl there's a lot of he said he said
middle-of-the-road NFL quarterbacks like
Blake bortles was there and guys like
that's like alright and there was a lot
of hot chicks all right I mean yeah that
that's what we're gunning for it the
Super Bowl that was we're very happy
with whether women being sexually
promiscuous I certainly hope not I mean
that's even back in the day we used to
do these blackout parties and that's
been misconstrued with that it was
literally black lights like it we
started in dorms the logo was just
putting a plug into an outlet and then
because of black lights it became EDM
parties basically and girls would dress
and tight little outfits white and
people just started attacking us and
then being like you guys are promoting
great cultures like how dancing you know
cuz they're dancing and what was it
because black out parties even though
you're saying it's for black lights it's
because you're supposed to get out
blackout drunk and then you have sex
with a woman who's blackout drunk that
would be great though those are like
wild leaps of but that was what that's
at the argument right and we had like
eyes there was actually a full-blown
protest it was called KO bar so this is
and we made a video of it and it was
about at Northeastern University they're
protesting me personally and I showed up
to the protest and they're screaming at
me and it was why take the high road and
they are screaming at me and then they
marched to where we're doing the House
of Blues in Boston and all you had one
group of I don't want to stereotype them
but overall they weren't the most
attractive group of women screaming at
screaming at the girls trying to get
into the party being like you don't
respect yourself and it's like that to
me is always the worst like who are you
to tell another girl how she should act
as she just only ought to have fun like
it's just a wild world does that even
ever freak you out like it's never been
a moment where like who we've all had
these clothes
calls or people complaining here people
well you like this is a problem so I
posted a way back on a picture of Tom
Brady's infants and his kid he was naked
it was infant like I'm talking like
Chrysler like baby on the time yeah it
was a picture of just thought it was a
paparazzi photo they're all over the
Internet
gizelle was on a beach with the kid and
I the blog was check out the howitzer on
Brady's kid looked like he had a huge
hog I stand by this and I made a joke
below it's like Peyton Manning I'm a
huge Brady guy I'm like Peyton Manning
could never have a kid like this that
was my joke I'm like that's a funny
thing whoa check out the howitzer I did
okay again the kid had to be like 20
seconds old like Amir and their baby
right like so absurd right that we all
know we're going for right correct that
became a huge issue the cops showed up
at my house it was but you didn't take
the photo or initially post it you were
just commenting on it I do I post it on
his site yeah it was a paparazzi photo
right it was all over the internet and
gizelle continued to do it be like this
is our cut like we do it wasn't like
taking four people may sound like I was
in a bush and took the photo myself not
the case that that's the only time on my
[ __ ] this children involved so what
happened how did it wait what would find
the only thing that I've really ever
like taken down myself like you know
cops basically said they were gonna make
my life difficult if I didn't okay but
it was like they knew what it was and
they probably couldn't do much about it
but you know this is not worth the
headache because of yeah okay right yeah
yeah this is not the battle to fight
right I mean if you have cops being like
we can really go through you they
everything like they can do anything we
want you if you don't know anything so
go to the media and say I just posted an
innocent nude photo of an infant and
that was one of them that's crazy
because I mean I really do stand by was
if the money goes right you know such a
I mean there were some people's like if
you think that if you're saying he was
sexualizing this then you should go like
get checked out because this kid's like
one day old you're in a good position
being here because we've all been in
like scenarios where we do and say
stupid things and like we worried about
getting fired we worry about the radio
show going away but bar still has done a
very good
of diversifying to the point where
should you say something stupid on
serious and serious is like look we have
to terminate the contract you can go
alright we go to let me go
at me just broadcast anyway we've been
terminated every single place we've been
except our stool right literally we've
never made it through cons right because
you but because you keep your like you
said in that cut in that bubble that
they can't break they can just remove a
little bit of money or remove the
contract but they can't [ __ ] your brand
it's been a huge advantage that's
probably let us get here as we got more
successful nobody could ever fire me
personally because I was a top guy so it
was like all right well I'm I'm still
here right nothing you can like people
who weren't familiar get fired it's like
who's gonna fire me what did you what is
your fear with Pashto is there any fear
you have like okay I got to make sure we
don't fall into this trap or we don't do
this wrong not not getting social
trouble but like just with the brand is
there anything that scares you like I
want to avoid this you know we're just
shooting for much we're playing for much
higher stakes since that was the big so
when I did the investment I sold half
the company now almost two years ago
we're trying to become a much bigger
brand so there's bigger factors that
play like the ESPN deal I wouldn't have
been interested and if we're not trying
to grow the brand so it's we somehow
miss what we're trying to get to and
lose what barstool is in the process
that would suck the videos you guys put
I mean we have a guy the guy way topic
does the video prep and a lot of the
interesting videos come from your it's
really what I've noticed it's amazing
with barstool is that now when I hire
guys who are under 20 like 27 and under
and I go like okay like I need you guys
to give me prep for the show cuz it's
not just answer I've had other guys to
do the exact same thing I get these show
prep emails and we've I've lit I've had
to scold multiple people and tell them I
don't need you sending me barstools
Instagram literally just like are still
opposed to this bar stool bar but it's
it you know I take it to Lake that's
that's when I really got the the reach
that barstool had now how like locked
yeah we're entrenched and I think a lot
of times even the people who criticize a
they just don't they just don't get
always like you're throwing like a rock
into a like you're not like
we have this foundation has been built
over 15 years so it's not easy to stock
it I don't think people understand the
depth of the audience or how loyal they
are or how like this is like barstool
becomes for a lot of these young guys
and girls I guess but you know in my
experience it's been guys like it's
their news source it's their sports
source it's their entertainment source
like they and they've been with Russia
for like since early high school
sometimes younger exactly you're not
like all right we don't like this joke
it's like I've been doing I've been
reading everything they've done for a
decade like Sam ponder criticizing us
does not change how I spent the last
decade I don't think a lot of people get
that about you but you said it you talk
to sports fans the way sports fans think
like sports fans don't normally think
the way ESPN point Lee everybody's
polite and PC they kind of think and
talk the way you got anything can talk
and that's why I think you're probably
you're you have that great defense
against every being totally taken down
because you say something rude totally
totally and you can see guys like yes
but you see them trying to make the
shift if you watch like the the segments
they do but they're so you can't just
turn it on you know suddenly we're gonna
be the fan oriented they look ridiculous
yeah you fake edge and as soon as one
person's upset like oh my god we didn't
mean it's not it's not it's not real so
it doesn't feel real I can't I can't
wait to do some digging after the show
today and talk to those rush guys and
see who's pissed about what is happening
to I'm gonna find out today cuz I want
it because I think if they're moving
even if they're moving just to another
channel or something they're still you
know we've been building this chin over
the let it's like that's my next ponder
in like three years
from that channel we'll just come with a
tweets like oh I didn't know I had a
grudge with this person Travis's timely
we have to break because we have to take
one more after this it's still
Presidente on Twitter president with an
e at the end of it and of course stay
portly it starts January on Sirius XM
here on channel 93 which is gonna
replace Rush and it's gonna be the
barstool sports channel which is gonna
be the entire 24 hours of you guys and
your ideas and your content yeah very
exciting I love seeing I love brands
that are real life and have been built
by like people you know not fun
company things that are corporate but
like you know this was a thing that
started
Hanan all newspapers and then it grew
and grew and it's and it's very similar
very similar vices is the the written
thing and all of a sudden that just
takes off and it just resonates with
people awesome so yeah you guys aren't
going anywhere